this cardiovascular machine is the r
cycle once on the machine you want to
adjust the seat by pulling the bar
underneath up and either lowering the
seat or pushing it higher
you then want to tighten the straps by
pulling the Black clip across until you
hear the click sound
you can then begin pedaling
you then compress the quick start button
which will put you on a 30 minute
workout and off you go
to increase the resistance on the back
you tap the plus button on the screen
where the yellow bar is and then you can
see the resistance increase
this is where your distance can be seen
this is also where your duration can be
seen
[Music]
and this shows you the Beats permanent
to finish the workout you will then
press the red pause button in the middle
of the screen
and then finish as shown
the machine will then show you a summary
of your workout
[Music]